[Musik]
[Applaus]
die bronzemedaille über vorfälle
realistischer das doppeltop jetzt
eigentlich nicht wenn es a bisserl
schockiert wie vielleicht auch seine
vorfreude total also wir sind
überwältigt also ohne im bundesheer
weide weg nie so lang und so weit
bürgern ist auch einmal rossini die
absicherung nach hinten und jedoch dank
denen dafür mein sport professionell
aussehen und wie sehr froh dass
unterstützen hat
wenn er natürlich nur äußerst stolz sein
dass unsere auch mühe und arbeiten die
wir in den einzelnen leistungszentrum
durchführen
dass er jetzt so von erfolg gekrönt sind
und so erfolgreicher sommerspiele
olympischer spiele hatten wir noch nicht
ich habe schon von einer medaille
geträumt aber ich war kein top favorit
an dem tag war ich sehr stark maintal
und ich habe mich sehr gut gefühlt weil
ich wir hatten sehr gute vorbereitungen
und es hat sich alles gelohnt
frank hier alle unterstützer an das
bundesheer an die ist eine sporthilfe an
sportlern oberösterreich an alle
anlieger verband an ganz österreich
[Musik]